ahora les voy a presentar el concepto de
atención la atención es sencillamente la
fuerza que existe ya sea dentro o
aplicada a una cuerda o cable usualmente
cuando se está levantando jalando algo
supongamos que tengo una pesa que es de
100 newtons y está suspendida de una
cuerda atada al techo vamos a dibujar
aquí
nuestro peso o nuestra pesa
de 100 y otros
que está suspendida de una cuerda
al techo
ya sabemos que la fuerza bueno si
estamos en el planes de tierra que de
esta presa que está siendo jala hacia
abajo por la gravedad y sabemos que
existe esta fuerza hacia abajo y es
igual a 100 minutos pero también sabemos
que esta pesa no se está acelerando de
hecho se encuentra estacionaria ya
tenemos aquí nuestra fuerza de gravedad
es igual a 100 minutos ojo no confundir
la fuerza de la gravedad en este peso
con respecto a la aceleración de la
gravedad es es diferente y notamos que
esto está suspendido de aquí entonces
está estacionaria no se está moviendo
para ninguna ningún lugar
no hay ninguna aceleración
entonces se bueno ese es un dato
importante la fuerza neta en este punto
debe ser cero de acuerdo con las leyes
de newton entonces cuál será la fuerza
en el sentido contrario la fuerza hacia
arriba
bueno esta fuerza que está que la cuerda
está aplicando el peso puede verse como
la fuerza de tensión o les vamos a poner
efe de fuerza de tensión
que es también la fuerza que se
encuentra dentro de la cuerda y que es
exactamente igual a la fuerza de
gravedad en este objeto
es por eso que este punto se mantiene
estacionario vamos a dibujar este punto
en otro color para que se note este es
el punto donde se encuentra
estacionaria
entonces quedamos que de mi fuerza hacia
arriba ese es el tema ante igual a 100
newtons también a mi fuerza de tensión
la tensión es solamente la fuerza de una
cuerda para que pueden conceptualizar lo
en las cuerdas de una guitarra la
atención en medias es lo que determina
su sonido mientras más jalen una cuerda
y mientras mayor sea su tensión más
agudo o más alta será su lote
cuando les venden las cuerdas de hecho
les dicen cuál es la atención que cada
cuerda debe tener o puede soportar esto
es importante si están construyendo un
columpio o un puente o algo en que deben
de soportar
la atención como ven es un concepto
familiar y conocido para ustedes bueno
ya explicando esto vamos a hacer un
ejemplo un poco más complicado vamos a
usar este mismo peso pero en lugar de
tenerlo anclado al techo vamos a agregar
un par de cuerdas más dos cuerdas más
una cuerda verde
está amarrada kim y sale
esta cuerda verde está
detenida
en el techo
y esta cuerda llega hasta el pecho
y aparte tenemos otra cuerda
vamos a dibujar una pared
del mismo color yo creo que del techo o
parecido no de un color cafecito
tenemos aquí hay dios bueno la pared
y de la pared tengo otra cuerda que está
amarrada a esta en este punto entonces
tengo dos cuerdas
cuál va a ser la atención en estas dos
cuerdas
bueno vamos a llamar a esta cuerda de 1
y mi cuerda amarilla de 2
bueno como en el primer problema este
punto está estacionaria lo voy a marcar
en un color rojo
este punto no se está moviendo en mi
arriba ni abajo ni a la derecha ni a la
izquierda se encuentra estacionaria
por lo que las fuerzas metas tanto en x
como en ya son 0
mi otra pregunta es cuál será el
contrapeso ya sabemos que en este punto
existe una fuerza que están jalando
hacia abajo el peso es la fuerza de
gravedad podemos asumir que los cables
no tienen peso cuál va a ser la fuerza
hacia arriba que vamos a tener bueno
vamos a analizar cada cuerda
de 2 esta cuerda está jalando a la
izquierda no tiene componente en ya no
está levantando nada cual acuérdate 1 es
la que está haciendo todo el trabajo de
levantamiento bueno vamos a descomponer
los elementos de este vector de 1 vamos
a dibujarlo como vector
un poco más grueso
este vector de 1
y vamos a
descomponerlo en sus elementos
horizontales y verticales
nuestro componente en o hacia arriba
es este y vamos a llamarlo de 1
subíndice
y aparte vamos a tener otro componente
que éste viene hacia acá
que lo llamaremos de 1 su índice x
muy bien se me olvidaba mencionar una
propiedad importante de este problema
que es necesaria para poder resolverlo y
es que el ángulo que forma este este
vector t1 con el techo
es un ángulo de 30 grados
sabemos que te 1x este es paralelo al
techo y por las propiedades de los las
líneas paralelas y los ángulos internos
alternados podemos saber que este ángulo
también será igual a 30 grados
y pudimos haberlo hecho de otra manera
sabemos que este es un triángulo
rectángulo este es un ángulo de 30
grados y este ángulo también sabemos que
debe de ser de 60 grados
pero bueno vamos a seguir usando
esta configuración
entonces
bueno cual es la componente de nuestras
funciones trigonométricas
seno coseno y tangente la que nos
involucra el cateto opuesto es nuestra
función seno
entonces vamos a usar
seno de 30 grados es igual a mika que
todo puesto que es mi componente en 71
sobre el cateto adyacente pero sobre la
hipotenusa y recordemos
qué bueno está hipotenusa la vamos se
llama t1 entonces este 1 sobre t 1
y despejamos lo que me interesa a
conocer qué es
es igual a
de uno por el seno de 30 grados
bueno y que decíamos antes de comenzar
con todos estos cálculos que todo el
levantamiento de este sistema se realiza
en la componente de btu no quedamos que
quite dos solo hallase la izquierda
entonces lo único que evita que el
objeto caiga este uno y por lo que tiene
que ser igual a la fuerza de la gravedad
tiene en el objeto que lo está jalando
hacia abajo
entonces bueno quiero que esto les quede
claro pues quizás sea un poquito confuso
este punto está estacionario no se mueve
sabemos que hay una fuerza hacia abajo
de 100 minutos
esta es la fuerza de la gravedad en este
punto
y t2 no está haciendo ninguna no tiene
ninguna componente hacia arriba toda la
fuerza hacia arriba viene del componente
en lleve t 1 ahora podemos calcular la
atención en la primera cuerda ya que
esto va a ser igual al me fuerza de la
gravedad
entonces tenemos
si nos recordamos nuestras equivalencias
en nuestros triángulos de 30 60 y 90
grados el seno de 30 grados es igual a
un medio entonces tenemos que de 1
subíndice y es igual a de 1 por el seno
de 30 grados que es un medio
y de uno ya quedamos que es la fuerza
igual a la fuerza de gravedad que 100
minutos
perdón esto debe ser igual a 100 minutos
este elemento que es nuestro equivalente
de nuestra componente t 1
bueno entonces si queremos saber de uno
pasamos este término
multiplicando al otro lado de la
ecuación y despejamos de uno es igual a
dos por de uno y queremos que t 1 y es
igual a 100 newtons por lo que mi
componente de la fuerza de mi vector t1
es de 200 minutos vamos a escribirlo
aquí esto vale 200 minutos
bueno ahora queremos saber la atención
en el segundo cable entre 2
de nuevo este punto está estacionario
por lo que cualquier que sea la atención
entre 2 deberá ser el contrapeso de la
atención que tengo en la componente x de
mi vector t 1 1
así que vamos a usarlo en un amarillo
de 2 es igual
mi componente de 1 en x
y como queremos saber ahora el cateto
yacente entonces
voy a usar este elemento que es 200 que
es mi componente t 1 200 minutos por el
coste no ya que estoy tratando con el
componente adyacente el coste lo de 30
grados y esto es igual a si nos
acordamos estoicos a 170 grados equivale
a raíz de 3 entre 2
por lo que tenemos 200
por raíz de 3 entre 2 que es igual a 100
por raíz de 3 minutos
y esta es la atención a la izquierda que
se está llevando a cabo
en este elemento se tenemos de 1 x es
este valor de 100 tiempo raíz de 3
newtons
es igual a 100 por raíz de 3 newtons
pero esto está ocurriendo hacia la
derecha de 2 es exactamente igual pero
se está en la dirección opuesta que es
hacia la izquierda entonces es 100 x
raíz de 3 minutos
bueno espero no haberlos confundido
demasiado nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo